the wait is almost over for Game of
Thrones fans the eighth and final season
starts this Sunday I mean massive
numbers this season because over 32
million people tuned into seven season
seven alone so says we've been with the
cast it's the very beginning well we
have learned a few things that fans
never knew shag marry kill okay Jon Snow
Oh Jaime Lannister haha and Ramsay she
okay well definitely kill Ramsay because
he's just no good we'll find out soon I
think I'd probably have to strike Jaime
Lannister and marry Jon Snow one thing I
think people don't know about you that
you're actually a descendant of royalty
yes according to Wikipedia that is true
naturally I am a blonde but not this
bunch but I can assure you bronze do
having fun sleep well what you didn't
know about your favorite game of Thrones
stars Emilia Clarke turned down the
Fifty Shades role of Anastasia Steele
why too much nudity and the violence
after nine nude scenes in Game of
Thrones Emilia confessed she didn't want
to be typecast in those type of roles
they said we're gonna get you a body
double and I was like no you're not if
it's gonna be my naked body then it
should be my naked body Jason Momoa is a
real-life model who got his start on
Baywatch EG was on set with him in 2002
and to get that sculpted body while
jason prefers or rock climbing over
spending time the gym
you know nothing Jon the smell
we all know co-stars Kit Harington and
Rose Leslie fell in love on set and got
married last year but did you know that
kit had to wear a wig for the Game of
Thrones pilot episode until he grew his
hair out
I understand actually as part of your
contract you can't cut your hair for
Game of Thrones no I can't no I have to
keep it like this no they don't want to
wig me and they don't like wigging so
for other projects I'm gonna pin it up
but this is this hair belongs to HBO now
when you play the game of Thrones you
win
will you die Cersei aka Lena Headey has
14 tattoos in real life all of them had
to be covered during shooting and after
his death at the red wedding which
Madden is being eyed to play the next
double-oh-seven
and ask for the bad boy who was in love
with his sister Nikolaj coster-waldau
things I do for love he had a very
memorable award show run-in with an
a-lister in the men's bathroom
I said saurian sorry and he said sorry
and then I go my god that's George he's
so short
[Music]
[Applause]